Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Really good
news, Marvel just announced that Tom Holland
has signed his brand new contract for a bunch of
new movies new Trilogy other movies I'll explain
what's going on is probably one of the best
things we could have heard from Tom Holland
in future Spider-Man stuff because there are a
lot of questions things are up in the air we all
expected him to come back but now we finally have
some confirmation about what that's going to look
like if you're brand new to the channel of course
I'll be doing all kinds of Spider-Man videos going
forward we have a bunch of Spider-Man stuff from
across the Multiverse like we have Spider-Man
freshman year episodes coming in a couple years
we have Andrew Garfield Tobey Maguire coming back
potentially for more cameos in other movies and
we have a version of Spider-Man that's supposed to
come back during what if season 2 and maybe even
the Marvel Zombies episodes but the big news of
the day is that Tom Holland's new contract is for
five movies right now that could change they could
add stuff to that later but it includes a new
Trilogy of solo Spider-Man movies like we all kind
of expected made by Marvel and Kevin feige like
the previous Spider-Man movies same exact Deals
they had before for those and two Avengers movies
full Avengers 5K Dynasty in Avengers 6 Secret Wars
beyond that when it comes to minor crossovers
for those of you asking for him to show up and
Daredevil born again it'd be awesome if Spider-Man
showed up during Daredevil episodes Daredevil is
definitely going to be showing up during the new
Spider-Man movies Tom Holland's new deal right now
is just for the movie stuff not for the TV the
Disney plus stuff or the one-off crossovers in
other movies any of those cameos they'd work out
one at a time on a movie by movie basis or a TV
show by TV show just depending on how much work it
would be for him and what his scheduling is like
because that's actually kept him from cameoing
a lot in previous stuff because he was so busy
making the previous Spider-Man movies at any given
time for example right now Tom Holland is supposed
to have a cameo scene in Spider-Man across the
spider-verse which is coming out next June I
just did a video about that so I'll add a link
for it in the description below Sony's working
on that they would have worked out a separate
one-off deal for that because it'd be such a
small thing like a very brief Cameo scene in a
just be voiceover and for instance I also just
did a Spider-Man freshman year trailer video from
Comic-Con a couple months ago so I'll post a link
for that in the description below too it's like
a whole separate thing Charlie Cox is coming back
as Daredevil during that like it will be Charlie
Cox himself voicing a version of Daredevil but
Spider-Man will not be voiced by Tom Han during
that they'll get a professional voice actor for
it and during what if season one Tom Holland
didn't voice that version of Spider-Man either
mainly like I said because of scheduling so in
the future he won't play every single version of
Spider-Man across all the different movies across
the Multiverse because Sony has all of their
Spider-Man related movies that they're trying to
make right now too with versions of Spider-Man
they want to keep Tom Holland from having to do
like 15 billion different movies back in the day
the original Avengers actors actually complained
about this when they first signed up in Marvel
phase one for their characters like Chris Evans
said he was forced to sign a six picture deal
or no deal at all nowadays they usually work out
deals for trilogies for new actors but for really
high profile actors like Willem Dafoe Alfred
Molina Jamie Foxx and Spider-Man no way home
those were just one-off deals so they can still
have Tom Holland show up in Daredevil born again
and in a small Cameo scene and just work that out
separately right before it happens because on top
of everything they're gonna have 18 episodes of
Daredevil Born Again plenty of space for all kinds
of cameos from all kinds of Marvel characters
not just the other Netflix Defenders characters
like Luke Cage Jessica Jones Punisher I'm pretty
sure that's all the major Defenders characters
I don't think I'm leaving anyone out there and
they'll actually be filming all those Daredevil
episodes pretty much the entirety of next year
like February to December that's how long they're
going to be filming so there's plenty of time to
work out Cameo deals for other people especially
Tom Holland they move pretty quickly when they
make Spider-Man movies so they might be able to
release Spider-Man 4 by July 2024. they typically
release Spider-Man movies in the middle of the
summer a lot of you know asking what's going to
be the plot of the new Trilogy what are the major
arcs that they're going to cover because there
are a couple big ones that they haven't got to yet
they made some big teasers during Spider-Man no
way home so we kind of have an idea of what that's
going to be for us too as well apparently work
they just if they keep scrolling it says and Tom
and Jaime get he does say that but they don't want
to scroll because they don't wanna you know what
they want to surprise us right that's what it is
it's a surprise exactly first it'll be following
Spider-Man through his college years that'll
either be him at Empire State like the comics
like the Toby Maguire version went to Empire
State or maybe even small chance maybe the
Future Foundation because of the Fantastic Four
because of what happened during no way home he
didn't get into MIT because of what the spell did
he had to get his GED and he's going to stay in
the New York City area for the most part so there
are only a couple options from the comics for that
that's Empire State and Future Foundation then
in a larger sense bit of a longer storyline is
the Spider-Man Venom symbiote Saga because of the
big venom post credit scene teasing that he left a
piece of the Symbiote behind that will eventually
find its way to Spider-Man also probably a lot of
other villains that are going to try and use
that symbiote as well too makes you think of
what happened during Spider-Man PS4 the other cool
thing about the new version of Tom Holland's Venom
symbiote Saga is that they can continue that
storyline through Secret Wars now and include
an Easter egg for the way that he got the Symbiote
in the comics originally in the 1980s version of
Wars when the beyonder transported them all to
battle world and they were doing battle through
the course of that his costume got damaged so
he tried to use the alien technology to repair
it this really advanced technology but the thing
that wound up replacing his costume with a black
costume wound up being the alien symbiote
they called it the alien costume later it
was retconned to be the Venom symbiote originally
it wasn't the alien costume it was Todd McFarland
that came along and did all that Venom stuff they
did a version of that Arc during the Toby Maguire
movies obviously the version they do during Tom
Holland's movies will be completely different
which is why I say they might actually drag that
through to Secret Wars because that would be
pretty cool Easter egg and obviously one of the
other big story lines the through lines of this
next Trilogy in the next two Avengers movies
is Spider-Man joining the new Avengers team
in Avengers 5 King Dynasty and just continuing
to be on that team in Avengers six Secret Wars
that last movie that's currently on his contract
Secret Wars would be coming out May 2026 so after
that Marvel and Sony would have to negotiate
another new deal for Tom Holland or focus on
Miles Morales solo is in the MCU or maybe just do
Tom Holland cameos for a little while from time
to time like a Hugh Jackman Wolverine or Patrick
Stewart Professor X situation where they do come
back but in kind of a limited way or for one-off
movies because I don't think they have any plans
to recast MCU Peter Parker Spider-Man for a
long a long time like when we got ready for
Spider-Man no way home Kevin feige said one of
the reasons why we hadn't seen MCU Green Goblin
or Dr Octopus or the Shocker for instance up
to this point is because he never considered
recasting those characters he always thought of
Willem Dafoe from the Toby movies as the Green
Goblin so when it comes to MCU Peter Parker I
think that'll be the same Tom Holland will be
Peter Parker and the MCU for a long time even if
at some point he wants to take a longer break and
they just want to focus on other versions of
Spider-Man plus you also have Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield that said that they would love
to come back and continue the stories of their
versions of Spider-Man so there are many many
versions of Spider-Man that they can pick from
across the Multiverse if Tom Holland wants to take
that break we should do this again again like I'll
hang out it's nice yeah for sure yeah it's a good
idea I'll just grab your number at the end of it
the battle you got it yes they probably did back
up a dump truck of money for him he probably
doubled his salary and probably got a couple
points in the back end I don't think they got
Robert Downey Jr money but what they might wind
up doing is just giving him a little bit more
Authority and allowing him to work on the script
with the director in the writers usually that's
the path for younger actors like once they gain
more experience they become more ingrained with
a role like Tom Holland has they give them more
Authority more control over future movies you may
have seen Tom Holland joking in the past about all
the notes that he gave the studio when they were
actually making the previous Spider-Man movies
there were all these ideas that he had that they
completely hated or ignored flat out mostly
because they were bad ideas like he clowned
on himself for giving them bad ideas but that was
because he was so young and so inexperienced a lot
of you now asking do they have plans to introduce
live-action Miles Morales during this new Trilogy
of Spider-Man movies he already exists in the MCU
he was mentioned by name in Spider-Man Homecoming
in the deleted scene but that happened before
the snap before the five-year time Jump and
now I actually think the more badass decision
that they could make would be to just make the
animated Miles Morales from the Spider-Man across
the spider-verse movies into the live-action
version as well like the new idea is at the end
of Spider-Man across the spider-verse part 2 he
just goes into the live-action MCU and he winds
up being live action because he traveled into
a live-action universe and that's the version
of Miles Morales that we see in future movies
so it's basically the same version that we've been
watching in these Spider-Man into the spider-verse
movies Lord and Miller already teased using live
action elements inside those Spider-Man across
the spider-verse movies I believe they're still
working out a deal for Zendaya to come back as
Mary Jane but she will come back in some way
if it's not for every single movie same thing
with Ned leads he might not come back quite as
much as Mary Jane does but remember this is all
about introducing brand new characters from the
comics into the Spider-Man universe that's why I
say they're going to work for new crossovers other
characters that we haven't seen before on screen
for example Crossing him over with Fantastic
Four characters including some of them in his
Spider-Man movies because why wouldn't you you do
that they appeared in Amazing Spider-Man number
one Kevin bigy's big thing when they introduced
Tom Hall and Spider-Man was doing stuff from the
original the very original Comics that's one of
the reasons why they went to the vulture because
he appeared so early in Spider-Man's comics and
the other thing I didn't mention earlier the other
like big new group of villains particularly they
could introduce would be a genuine version of the
Sinister Six because we kind of did a version of
that during Spider-Man no way home but they never
actually refer to themselves as the Sinister Six
and because they changed their minds and Venom was
not at the Statue of Liberty fight there weren't
actually six villains there and Doctor Octopus
even switched sides so when you really get down to
it they never were actually the Sinister Six which
just means that they can do an authentic version
they'd actually do call themselves The Sinister
Six in future movies but I'm really glad this all
worked out of course I'll do a bunch more videos
for Spider-Man 4 when we get more announcements
and we learn more details about what's going on
if you have any other big questions about
the future of Spider-Man just in general is
a character across all the different Spider-Man
properties and TV shows and movies they're making
just write it below in the comments black panther
wakanda forever is coming out this weekend I just
posted my review video you can click here for
that and click here for my black panther what
kind of forever post credit scene video I'll
update the link as soon as I post that later
this week thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!